[Music]
this is a picture that was taken with a
very high-end camera and so it will help
us illustrate
the feature we're trying to achieve
so let me bring up a picture you see in
this beautiful portrait the gentleman
the front is pin sharp in focus
and that background has a beautiful blur
this is called shallow depth of field
it's something that is illustrative of a
great camera that has often a very big
sensor like a full-frame sensor or
a really big fast lens and the quality
of that background blur that's what's
called bokeh
and the higher the quality of the bokeh
usually the more advanced and higher
quality the lens and camera system so
our goal is to try to do something like
this using the two cameras in the iphone
7 plus this is a incredible breakthrough
so now i'm going to show you the first
picture we've ever shown the world of a
depth of field photo taken from an
iphone 7 plus with this new feature the
picture i showed you before this was
taken on an iphone 7 plus
portrait mode that's probably a phrase
you've heard a lot more about lately you
know portrait mode this live focus that
depth effect over here shallow depth of
field over there the first time we
really saw this portrait mode start to
actually make an impact on smartphones
was an iphone of course it was the
iphone 7 plus this thing came out with
dual cameras one normal and one
telephoto and this this beta portrait
mode in ios 10. and it was garbage like
it really was trash when it first came
out but apple stuck with it worked on it
and a couple software updates later it's
gotten better and better so now here we
are in 2017 and you can see pretty much
every other phone coming out has these
dual cameras feels more like a rule than
an exception we actually kind of wonder
if a new phone comes out and it doesn't
have dual cameras like what the deal is
so here's the question how well has
portrait mode actually gotten through
these software updates over the years
and how well does it actually compare to
a legit professional camera like this
here this is
the hasselblad x1d
this is the type of sensor it's a big
sensor camera that like apple said that
they're emulating it's a medium format
sensor and it's amazing now medium
format refers to the sensor size so you
may have heard of full frame cameras
with their huge 36 by 24 millimeter
sensors well medium format sensors are
even larger than full frame 43.8 by 32.9
millimeters this sensor is incredible it
also recently happened to get the
highest ever score on dxomark of 102 if
you're into that but bottom line i've
had this for a couple months now and i
love it i've taken the best photos i've
ever taken in my life with it you can
check the flickr i'll link it below so
it's that's what we're comparing it to
so here i have iphone 10
galaxy note 8 and google pixel 2 all of
which have really really high-end
cameras and of course they all have a
portrait mode to try to emulate
what this guide does so let's see how
they stack up all right so here's what i
would consider your standard portrait
mode example same photo same angle from
iphone 10 galaxy note 8 pixel 2 and the
hasselblad and you can see some
differences right off the bat and then
when i put them all side by side
especially of course how the hasselblad
does it so well and here's just another
one so you get a better idea iphone 10
galaxy note 8
pixel 2
and the hasselblad now what you're going
to start to notice is that portrait mode
on these smartphone cameras it does a
pretty good job of replicating the
general effect of a shallow depth of
field but of course none of them are
perfect and there are a couple main
differences in how they handle it so
number one is what i'll call edge
detection this camera doesn't need edge
detection software because it just kind
of has a plane of focus if your object
is out of the plane of focus too close
or too far away it'll be blurred out and
everything in that plane will be sharp
simple as that but a smartphone sensor
is so small and the lens is so wide
angle that for most normal photos almost
everything is just going to be in focus
so to create this nice blur on the
background you either need to get really
close to the subject or it needs some
kind of edge detection or depth sensing
to determine what's in the foreground
keep it sharp and then what's in the
background and blur it out now different
phones do this different ways so galaxy
note 8 and iphone 10 both have dual
cameras and they use the difference in
depth difference between those cameras
to sense distance so the same way we use
our eyes to see in 3d and the google
pixel 2 is actually one that does this
all with split pixel technology so a
difference in distance between adjacent
pixels which is really impressive which
is why i called this thing so smart so
while none of these do a perfect
replication as you've seen they all
handle it to varying degrees of success
like the more you shoot portrait mode on
the iphone 10 for example the more you
realize apple basically just takes the
face
make sure that's in focus and then blurs
pretty much everything else not just the
background
everything even if it's supposed to be
in the same plane of focus your ears
hair shirt the rest of your body
everything else will be blurred it just
seems kind of sloppy sometimes the
galaxy note 8 does a pretty good job
actually with edge detection but again
it's obviously not perfect and then
you'll see the pixel 2 is is maybe the
most artificial looking but also
possibly the most pleasing looking
result it cuts the edges the most
sharply and then goes really far to
separate them by sharpening the subject
a bit and blurring the background the
most so then the number two thing and
you might not think about this as much
is the blur variation the differences in
amount of blur so it's not just as
simple as taking the entire background
and blurring it all out that would be
simple but it's a bit more complex with
photos from a high-end camera the amount
of blur is actually dependent on not
just the focal length but how far into
the background that subject is so the
things that are further from the plane
of focus are more blurred and the things
that are closer are less blurred so
smartphone cameras believe it or not are
actually getting better at also doing
this pretty well you can see in this
shot it's an actual gradient of the
amount of blur you're supposed to have
and thanks to the depth sensing
abilities it kind of does it you can see
it probably is best handled by the pixel
2 here they all still do it uh but it's
probably the most dramatic with the
pixel 2. it's not quite what the
hasselblad is doing but it's decently
close and then there's other small
things like distance and brightness and
exposure pickiness portrait mode doesn't
always work on a smartphone now
obviously you put the 90 millimeter lens
on the hasselblad and the background
will be blurred every single time but
with portrait mode on the smartphone
it's not exactly universal earlier i
said the best way to guarantee blurring
the background from a smartphone camera
is to get the subject really close to it
portrait mode basically just extends
that range of background blur to photos
a couple feet away six eight feet away
but again once you get too far away
portrait mode will stop working as well
and the iphone will tell you about it
it's very vocal about placing your
subject within eight feet and telling
you when it isn't going to work so if
you're too far away it's just gonna take
a normal photo with no portrait mode and
same with note 8 but it mostly just says
due to shooting conditions so it's not
as specific but you kind of just have to
know how to fix it and pixel 2 has no
warning at all it actually doesn't give
you a preview of the background blur so
you don't know if it worked or not until
after you take the shot and then let it
process and then look at it and see if
it worked sometimes it fails and you
don't know till later so a shot like
this when you're too far away they tend
to not be able to tell the difference as
easily between the foreground and the
background so a large sensor camera
still makes a solid amount of bokeh but
usually your smartphone will just go
back to taking a normal photo and then
your other weird quirk with these is
just non-human subjects or things that
aren't your typical portrait or stuff
with weird outlines this artificial
intelligence has been training itself on
like this normal human portrait for so
long that it does best with that it's
done pretty well with pets also
interestingly enough i've noticed but
then it breaks down like when you see
stuff like this headphone picture this
is what i'm talking about it becomes
pretty obvious they get a lot of the
outside of the blur down but then
there's like holes in the middle and
awkward lines and things where again
edge detection can be weird but here's
the thing the biggest difference between
these smartphone cameras and the
hasselblad and things like this is
smartphone cameras are improving
way faster the whole background blur
thing smartphones are closing the gap on
slowly but they're also adding unique
features that big cameras can't touch
like artificially changing lighting
effects as soon as you take the photo or
tweaking the amount of background blur
after the photo was taken we aren't
getting noticeably new big features like
this nearly as quickly in dslrs or
mirrorless cameras but you can just push
a software update to a phone and get new
stuff like this all the time so mobile
photography is an awesome place to be
right now because you can do amazing
things with your smartphone camera that
you couldn't do a year or two ago now as
someone that takes a lot of photos with
a lot of different types of cameras from
the smartphones to the mirrorless
cameras to the hasselblad and everything
in between i've always been able to tell
the difference between a smartphone
photo and a dedicated camera always but
this year with these new cameras
is the closest it's ever been it's the
most blurred that line has ever been i
think you and i will always be able to
tell the difference if you pixel peep
enough between a smartphone camera and a
big sensor just because of the physical
constraints of trying to make such a
small sensor do such big things and so
for that reason the big cameras will
always have their place professionals
will always buy that but these cameras
are getting so good and they still have
their advantages of being so small and
portable and always with you that
getting like a really high quality
selfie or really high quality photo
wherever you are without having to worry
about your big camera is the biggest
advantage of a smartphone so dslrs and
dedicated cameras for that
professionalism and quality but
smartphone cameras for portability and
ease of use i think bottom line that's
what they're good at and the best camera
really is still just the one you have
with you i don't think that'll change
for a while but this is what gets me
excited about the next year or two of
smartphones and smartphone cameras and
what they get really good at so that's
what we have to look forward to so
thanks to these companies dedication to
this stuff it'll only get better from
here either way that's been it thank you
for watching talk to you guys the next
one
peace
[Music]
you